G1 was so
amazing that I had never
experienced it before, it was a scenery I had never seen before. No matter
how much I practiced, I didn't feel like I could win.
[Music] I was
scared, but to be honest,
I was a little aware that even if I tried hard,
I could do it. [Music]  It wasn't. I'm a
cool, sparkling star.
But I still
want to win. I'll do my best again from now on, so please
give me some guidance.
[Music] A
diamond has a method that shines at its finest.
No amount of hardship can
break it.
But be yourself and be yourself.
Run
[Music]
Until this hand that won't give up reaches you
TV anime Uma Musume Pretty Derby
Season 3 Broadcast starts in October 2023